Lily and dindo is a clinical
psychologist and she has a website
called
actfinderpath.com
yes great and by the way for people who
are interested ACT therapy stands for
acceptance commitment therapy that has
saved my life when I was going through
what I've been told is called The Dark
Knight of the Soul so it's something
like uh it's a Well we can talk about
that another time but I've watched much
of Lillian's work on YouTube her
her lectures and they keep like man oh
man like every time I'd watch it it's
like taking what I imagine is a
benzodiazepine it's just just and and
and
anxiolytic okay and Greg Henriques is
someone who's had me on his podcast I'm
lucky for he has his own toe called the
unified theory of knowledge and is
someone that I would like to have on the
toe podcast but much like almost anyone
else who has a toe and wants to come on
toe I have to study for months in
advance so I haven't had you on Greg
until now because I want to go deep into
your toe I know that sounds a bit odd
and Jesse Mitchell
like we're friends you have a great
YouTube channel that everyone is jealous
of including myself
and it's called
Sam is here Sam is also corroborating
that he it's called it's called American
Alchemy so I'm doing this all for memory
just so you know and Grant's Cameron
UFO researcher fellow Canadian we worked
behind the scenes on a
on something or at least we try to and
and I want to well I want to thank you
all for coming I know that this is an
odd Bunch but none of you are odd I'm
saying the mixture the Confections
good morning
the interweaving okay so what did I miss
out Greg can you tell me that we'll go
Jesse Lillian then Grant what did I miss
um I'm a professor of psychology cool to
have a act person here uh I love act I
talk a lot about act uh um and uh I just
uh released a book uh so you said
Shameless plug here a new synthesis for
solving the problem of psychology
addressing the enlightenment gaps the
sort of the latest articulation of kind
of how some of my work and theoretical
Clinical Psychology can uh dress the
bridge between biology and psychology
the social sciences
yes and then Jesse and then Lily and
then Grant
what did I miss him most of your podcast
Kurt but I I which I love and thank you
for having me and I think it's so cool
uh to get this odd intersection of
people together but um uh Jesse Michaels
I have a YouTube channel like you
mentioned American Alchemy uh before
that I I worked for Peter Thiel who's
kind of you know venture capitalist an
entrepreneur for four years and before
that I was at Google actually so I kind
of have a tech background but am really
interested in in media and also just
kind of uh
similar to you Kurt I think I have a uh
uh basically unsatiable uh interest in
getting to the the fundamental nature of
reality and then I think you do it in a
far more kind of analytical math science
way and I do it in like a wacky way it's
the way I would put it
yeah great great and Lillian please hi
hi everyone nice to be with you all
um I think you covered it I mainly
um a researcher a clinical I'm a
clinical psychologist but mainly do
research
um on how to find innovative ways to
disseminate act actually into the
population because
a regular type of therapy going weekly
every week for months doesn't actually
reach most people so trying to find
innovative ways to reach more people
great and before we get to Grant I want
to touch on that point something I
recall from your lecture so you can
correct me if this is incorrect
is that you have a program and I think
this may be generally
offered where it's four hours long or
five hours a day long it's an intensive
which means that you go and then you
learn about ACT therapy and then you
don't it's always useful if you continue
to go to therapy but you don't need to
and you can see several benefits whereas
traditional therapy or Psychotherapy you
go once a week and if you don't go once
a month or so or once every or bi-weekly
you see a huge tapering you don't get
the results now so what's correct or
incorrect about that yeah so I developed
a one-day act Workshop so it's kind of
like a retreat style and it's about five
to six hours uh very experiential
um so you get essentially the entire
protocol in one day and that's meant to
kind of
get behind you know
get the whole treatment in one day
because the problem is treatment
adherence and completion is a big
problem and so yes and we've done
multiple studies that are funded by NIH
and the VA that have found that actually
this one day intervention is effective
at reducing depression improving anxiety
functioning quality of life so on so
some people do need boosters I need a
booster myself all the time uh so I need
one right now yeah exactly so but it is
you know you learn a lot of the
processes experientially during that day
um and it's quite intensive and Powerful
I found while research has found
empirically Grant Cameron
what did I miss out in your introduction
man
um I've been in the Paranormal business
since uh shortly after they invented
dirt
um I have um I I have a a podcast uh
called uh paranormal UFO Consciousness
podcast and I have a YouTube which is uh
the White house UFO YouTube site I've
just released three books and I guess
the the main book that is just coming
out now is on the UFO Sky Pilots which
deals with 36 plus Witnesses who claim
that they have flown the craft and I go
through the pattern of what they
describe they're all describing the same
thing how it relates to Consciousness
and the theory of you know reality and
all this kind of stuff and and I've also
had released a weird book called it was
actually called weird the Paranormal
world of ports and manifestations which
I think is one of the first books ever
written on it and that's uh whether you
have physical mediums or Poltergeist
Geist or UFO experiences where things
will appear disappear move around the
room this sort of stuff and I have a
whole collection of stuff from various
uh places around the world
okay well I have no plan for this
collection of cats it's difficult to
herd
so let's see
well firstly just like man this is just
fun thank you all for coming out
spending December 30th it's a fairly
sacred day it's almost like Christmas
near the end of the year thank you thank
you so let's see what what is it Lily
we'll start with you because you have to
get going in about five minutes what is
it about 2022 that I know that's putting
on the spot like what story from 2022
sticks out to you the most is most
relevant and what is the best Insight
from your work
right right
um what's your second question second
question comes from the audience
quote-unquote the best Insight from your
work
the best in
in my work
um I think after years and years
come to recognize that like awareness is
the most important first step to things
like you have to be aware of
your triggers you have to be aware of
your thought processes the emotions of
the moment like if you don't have that
that awareness first then so much is on
autopilot I feel
um and so I've just come to realize this
awareness idea is just so important
um
you know we can ask you a question about
that if you don't mind of course
so what about if someone's issue that
they're coming to act for is because
they have too much self-awareness
where they feel like I'm constantly
thinking about Consciousness and I feel
like I'm almost having a psychotic break
so I'm speaking about my former self at
least and somewhat my current self and
so to say oh I need more awareness like
no no awareness is hurting me right now
hurting me right now
well I think what you're describing is
more like rumination and obsessiveness
actually it's not so much true awareness
in the way I'm thinking of it I mean
awareness is recognizing like okay I am
going down a rabbit hole here I am I am
being obsessive now I am ruminating now
um so it's actually more like developing
an insight into where you get stuck and
then
um where you get triggered and then so
even being aware of where I'm so sorry
to interrupt you it's so difficult when
it's over Zoom because I I apologize but
what I was going to say is like so in
that case you would say being aware that
what you're calling awareness is too
much like just being aware it's almost
like a meta awareness
it's like stepping outside of yourself
and recognizing like okay like right now
I am ruminating like I am in this you
know phase of rumination or I'm
obsessing about this thing and how does
how does doing this move me forward in
my life you know so it's Step One is the
awareness and step two is
is this is you know is being stuck on
this thought process is being stuck on
this
um you know what whatever you're
ruminating about is this moving me
forward in my life
or is it keeping me stuck how does
buying into a particular thought
um affect my behavior next
so I I'd be interested in hearing what
Greg what you think about this too
you're a psychologist
yeah no certainly I mean uh I'm a big
fan of act I'll I'll certainly start
there I cultivate in training my uh doc
students awareness acceptance and change
uh active change in relation uh I built
a thing called com Mo which is basically
it merges act in what's called
interpersonal neurobiology uh and
certainly this capacity just step
outside become an observer in
relationship to that be able to accept
where you are and then be committed to
motivated stop valued states of being
and be able to reflect on that in a way
that isn't reactive or defensive or
brittle or rigid that's a beautiful
thing if you can learn how to do it so
I'm all in support
I I'm willing I I'd like to ask everyone
before I leave to just
think about something if that's okay
Kurt you said we could just ask
questions so I'm going to ask you yeah
please please do
um and I think I'm I'm gonna do this
just because it's the new year coming up
and
um it's an act move so let's do it so I
want everyone on here today just to
imagine that it's 15 years from now you
know that it's 15 years from now and
you've continued living your life
exactly as you're living it right now
you don't make any changes
so I want you now you're referring to us
five as well as the people in the
audience everyone just everyone I mean
this is an exercise I like to do pretty
regularly
um
so imagine it's 15 years from now and
you you're living exactly as you are now
and you don't make any changes
so complete the following sentences
I spent too much time
I spent too little time
and if I could go back in time what I
would like to do differently is
does anyone want to share
if you can briefly share because Lily
and I know you have to get going in
maybe three minutes can you stick around
for three more minutes Lillian okay
great
who wants to share
okay I'll go
um basically what it would come down to
is you look at near-death experiences
I'm sure I've learned from that is that
I spend too much time down the rabbit
hole not enough time with family and
when it comes down to the last minutes
of your life what's most important is
your family and the time you didn't
spend with them
yeah so for me I pictured
I always picture my wife whenever I
think of exercises whenever I have
exercises like this and I spend I always
prioritize her but I I could spend more
time with her and definitely I could
spend more time with family so my mom
and dad and and I feel like I work too
much though I love it and interestingly
enough I feel like I would be more
unhealthy I love junk food like I love
it but I abstain from it I abjure it and
I and I feel like I can I can indulge
some more but anyway Jesse and Greg
if you don't mind if you could be yeah
sure I mean uh you know I'm I love
contact with the present moment and I
still get pulled away further than I do
um so I'm always looking to expand uh
the Deep appreciation the awe that I
have for being in the world
um and taking time for gratitude and on
relationship to that uh also then
connecting to that which I love
um which I'm fortunate to be able to do
because I you know I have my work and
I'm able to do that
um but being that and having gratitude
for being that I'm able to achieve some
of that I could always do more of that
I'm similar I think I'm uh
way too kind of go-orient or future
oriented rather like I live I sort of
sacrifice the present for the future a
lot and I don't sort of you know wake up
and smell the roses and just enjoy
myself and do kind of uh spontaneous
things on a whim and uh often the best
things come from that kind of childlike
Instinct and so I wanna I wanna indulge
that more over the next 15 years
were those correct were those okay
do we get points there's no I mean
I mean how many times I do this it's
like for me it's always like I spend too
much time worrying about if I'm doing
enough if I am enough if you know and
it's just incredible that that stays no
matter but it's a good reminder like
okay I want to be
you know I want to be more in the moment
like you said Greg
um and then you know I'm sure you've all
heard about this book
um the top 10 regrets of the dying yeah
have you heard about it it's like it's
such a beautiful
um book that a palliative care nurse
wrote you know she just documented all
the things that these dying patients
said they regretted and what's amazing
is that you know our regrets are all
very similar you know we worry too much
we don't connect with our families too
much we we're not spontaneous enough so
yeah there's always that question that
they ask you know when somebody's
ruminating about something and say are
you going to be worrying about this on
the last day yeah when you're going to
die it's like no well then don't worry
about it no
okay Lillian I know you got to get going
I for everyone happy New Year website
again is please say it
please Lily can you repeat the website
and then also put it on sorry Act
findyourpath.com Act findyourpath.com is
also going to be on the screen in just a
moment thank you so much Happy New Year
everyone
all right you just watched a clip from
an eight hour live stream Behemoth
Leviathan podcast from theories of
everything which is a channel where we
explore physics mathematics and
Consciousness what is the Theory of
Everything how do you merge Quantum
field Theory with General relativities
click here or in the description for the
full podcast where there are several
people make appearances all the way from
George Knapp to Jeremy Corbell to Gary
Nolan to Avi loped John vervecki to
Donald Hoffman to Michael Levin to Ian
mcgilchrist and 40 more all in one eight
hour long podcast links in the
description